il y a des personnages sympas qui
entrent et sortent de la franchise et je suis
toujours ravi de les rencontrer et de les
regarder en action, nous avons passé beaucoup de temps à
réfléchir à qui s'intègre dans le monde
de Fast and Furious avec Jason Statham
dans ce  fait une énorme différence
James tenait vraiment à ce que j'entre
là-bas avec un peu de fracas, je veux dire pour
l'équipe qui a paralysé mon frère, c'est une
idée brillante pour moi d'entrer et de faire
des dégâts à un gars que vous ne pourriez
jamais  faire des dégâts au fil des ans, j'ai
eu l'occasion de combattre beaucoup de
durs à cuire d'Hollywood la Jason Statham
il est aussi annoncé comme un dur à cuire
tu es bon
Kurt Russell est l'un de mes acteurs préférés
je pense avoir vu presque tous les films
il était là et nous étions tellement
ravis qu'il ait même eu l'
idée de venir jouer avec nous vous les
connaissez quand je lisais vos fichiers
j'ai été impressionné par ce que vous avez
accompli avec son équipe mais les
rencontrer maintenant j'ai un coffre-fort  tu as vraiment un
cadeau Kurt  Russell était tellement amusant
de travailler avec vous pouviez dire dès
le début qu'il était fier
de ne pas faire partie du
football rapide revenons une ombre
[Musique]
on nous dit que le personnage de Ramsey est  un
activiste et nous supposons tous que ça
va être un gars ringard et
s'avère ensuite être Natalie Emmanuel le nouveau
personnage Ramsey elle est un peu comme la
version féminine de moi-même ce qu'elle
nous donne beaucoup d'humour un grand sex-appeal et vous
croyez que cette fille pourrait  être cette
activiste, elle est vraiment bonne,
je pense que l'aspect Ronda
Rousey change la donne
deux femmes vêtues de belles robes dans un
magnifique penthouse, c'est l'un des meilleurs
combats que nous ayons jamais eu dans la franchise
par le thème du combat des super œstrogènes
et je peux '  J'attends de voir la boutique
là-bas
. J'adore Ronda Rousey et je savais qu'elle
allait passer un moment très spécial.
Raja est peut-être l'athlète le plus incroyable
que j'aie jamais vu de ma vie.
L'action de pêche au rouleau de décrochage Telugu
c'est mon dur à cuire collectif
donnez-nous la fille non non vous apprenez que le temps est
juste le gars le plus gentil du monde mais il
a cette intimidation avec très peu de
mots 3 J'étais très excité à l'idée de
monter à bord aussi c'est un personnage très puissant
très vrai Wow ne s'arrêtera à
rien
[Music]
nous avons toujours eu l'habitude d'amener des
gens dans la franchise chaque fois que
quelqu'un d'autre apparaît, cela ajoute juste une
toute autre dimension que nous n'avions jamais eue
auparavant
[Music]
vous